nos encontramos en la población de sap
orilla que se ha convertido en una
ciudad estratégica para las personas que
huyen de mariupol o de muchas otras
ciudades en el sur de ucrania hoy en
control de las fuerzas rusas nos dicen
que en los últimos días han llegado 29
mil personas 8.000 de ellos niños pero
en este momento nos encontramos frente a
otra dinámica que no esperábamos y es 50
coches que están listos para empezar su
camino rumbo a mariupol allí esperan
recoger tanto a sus padres a sus esposas
a sus hijos oa personas queridas o
muchos de ellos incluso también hemos
visto que se van a quedar ahí o en sus
casas por fuera de mariupol porque dicen
que no tienen otro destino donde estar
lo que también hemos visto como muchos
de estos coches van llenos de alimentos
leche medicinas y muchísimos productos
que ya no se encuentran dentro de la
ciudad ha sido también interesante ver
como ellos llegan a poder ir tienen que
inscribirse frente a las fuerzas
ucranianas solamente dos personas coches
están autorizados y cada uno llegará
hasta la entrada de mariupol una vez
haya les han dado un mapa y cada uno
tomará el destino para llegar a sus
casas saben que es peligroso saben que
es difícil pero están dispuestos a
hacerlo